today Final Fantasy 14 is one of the
most popular MMOs with a passionate fan
base but that definitely wasn't always
the case the game completely failed
before popping a phoenix down and coming
back to life and this is how
[Music]
the year is 1999.
with the mass adoption of the internet
the idea of what multiplayer RPGs could
be was growing you had games like
Neverwinter Knights not not that one but
this one pushing the limits what players
could do online in 1997 Richard Garrett
coined the phrase MMORPG for the latest
installment of the long-running RPG
series Ultima Ultima Online but nothing
would make a splash quite like 1999's
EverQuest it quickly surpassed the
Behemoth of the time Ultima Online in
subscriptions whereas Ultima Online
peaked at 250 000 subscriptions
EverQuest more than doubled that with a
peak of 550 000 active accounts it also
won gamespot's coveted game of the year
for PC games hey wait that's us don't
look at me though I wasn't allowed to
play a request I didn't even hit puberty
yet back in Japan or rather Hawaii
actually hiranobu sakaguchi creator of
Final Fantasy was working on Final
fantasy's future film The Spirits within
at the time time sakaguchi developer
squaresoft and the Final Fantasy
franchise were on top of the world Final
Fantasy VII had released two years prior
in 1997 and went on to sell over 10
million copies becoming PlayStation's
second highest selling game of all time
Final Fantasy 8 released in 1999 closely
trailed at selling 8.6 million copies so
sakaguchi San set up square pictures in
Hawaii to work on a major feature film
for the franchise and to Surf I'm
actually being half serious sakaguchi
absolutely loves surfing and it's my
hunch that he chose Hawaii for that
reason and not because you know it's
like right in between Japan and the
mainland States whatever I do the same
thing in his position
anyways while in Hawaii
discovered and was impressed by Western
MMOs especially EverQuest it was then
the hironobu sakaguchi decided that it
was time to create a final fantasy
MMORPG so let's fast forward to the
future oh
Devante stop stop doing this to me
2000 Final Fantasy 9 comes out to 5.5
million sales still okay but much worse
than ff7 and 8. 2001 Final Fantasy the
spirits within the movie from square
pictures releases and it's a big old
flop so much so Enix almost didn't merge
with square as they were worried about
how much money they'd lost on the film
2001 Final Fantasy 10 also releases
thankfully it's a big success and sells
8.5 million units and we arrived at
2002. you don't know who sakaguchi's
MMORPG idea finally coming to fruition
it's Final Fantasy XI
and it's doing uh oh okay the amount of
time money and investment in Final
Fantasy 11 couldn't be matched by
initial sales as the game had cost
roughly 17 to 25 million dollars to make
there's also the fact that you need to
maintain an online game and can't just
ship it plus Square was working on
expansions that is at least in its first
year but luckily with MMOs you get that
sweet revenue from subscription fees
while today many MMO games are free to
play and use other means of making money
back during the Everquest days it was
standard to have a monthly fee in order
to play the game and with Final Fantasy
XI Daffy was about 12 bucks a month so
by December 2003 thanks to these regular
fees over a year after's Japanese
release Final Fantasy 11 was finally
breaking even and amazingly by 2012
Square enix's then CEO yuichiwata stayed
at Final Fantasy 11 had become the most
profitable Final Fantasy game ever but
of course times were moving on and in
2004 another little game you've probably
never heard of came out
so I'll let you in on it
bad Boys Miami Takedown
I'm coming what the hell also World of
Warcraft
while online gaming was definitely
getting bigger and bigger World of
Warcraft was a phenomenon by 2008 we're
talking over 10 million monthly
subscribers that's on top of the fact
that you also had to purchase a retail
copy of the game so while Final Fantasy
11 was profitable for square I mean it's
not 10 million monthly subscribers
profitable so they wanted a serious
competitor to World of Warcraft so in
2005 one year after the release of World
of Warcraft planning on Final Fantasy 14
began nobuyaki Komodo who was a director
on Final Fantasy 11 would direct 14 and
hiromichi Tanaka who had worked on
multiple Final Fantasy games and
produced Final Fantasy XI would act as a
producer then E3 2009 14 was announced
for a 2010 release date and after an
alpha test in March of 2010 and beta
test in early September the game was
released on September 30th to PC and oh
of 49 out of 100 on Metacritic with a
user score of 3.9 out of 10. nobuo
uemasu's Music deserves better Final
Fantasy 14 compared to other MMOs of the
time did have some impressive elements
to it for example the graphics were far
superior and your character didn't look
like their hair was a block of cheese
and as I mentioned Nobu oimatsu was one
of the composers on The Game and his
music is pretty much always insanely
awesome but it was glitchy and had
horrendously unintuitive gameplay
systems and was viewed as a worse game
than Final Fantasy 11. by Final Fantasy
11 fans who were you know the target
audience players were pissed the user
interface was so bad it was like
fighting with the game itself to play
and in general the gameplay just wasn't
fun according to now director of ff14
naoki Yoshida who would later work on A
Realm Reborn the architecture in just
how the servers were set up were already
problematic they were broken if your
server has a problem and you're trying
to make an online RPG it's like your
planet is deficient remember how I
mentioned you typically had to pay a
monthly subscription fee for MMOs well
in order to entice players to keep
playing they'd typically give you a free
30-day trial after you purchase the game
but ff14 was viewed so poorly and had so
many players pissed that Square Enix
extended that 30-day trial not once but
twice eventually monthly fees for the
game were suspended both nobuyaki Komodo
and hiromichi Tanaka were taken off the
project and Tanaka took responsibility
the game was supposed to release on both
PC and PS3 but was indefinitely delayed
for the PS3 I'm Still Holding Out for
that PS3 1.0 release
any day now I'm telling you here's how
poorly Final Fantasy 14 performed for
Square Enix for the fiscal year of 2011
Square Enix dropped its estimated income
for the Year by 90 percent at the 2011
Tokyo game show CEO yuichiwada
apologized for Final Fantasy 14 and
stated that Final Fantasy as a brand had
been greatly damaged by it
but like a phoenix Final Fantasy 14
would arise again while Square Enix was
absolutely reeling from the disaster
that was Final Fantasy 14 instead of
investing more into it and trying to
further convince players to play the
game they decided to do something kind
of crazy after essentially five years of
development in 2011 Square Enix decided
to scrap the entire game and basically
start fresh that is a lot of lost money
so April 2011 development began on Final
Fantasy 14 2.0 which would later be
dubbed Around Reborn naoki Yoshida who
had worked as the chief planner in
2012's Dragon Quest 10 was brought in to
take charge as both the director and
producer on this new version of Final
Fantasy 14. as I mentioned in yoshida's
previous quote he discovered that the
architecture of the game was
fundamentally flawed so we had the team
create a brand new game engine and
server structure in order to win back
fan trust Yoshida had the team maintain
the original ff14 while working at a
realm were born and began writing
letters from the producer in January
2011 a series of posts where he would
address fan concerns and feedback while
being as transparent as possible in
these posts he'd reveal the results of
polls The company took and genuinely
took the time to respond in a meaningful
and respectful way in his first post he
made it clear the team was taking fan
concerns seriously and were actively
trying to address the problems and
revealed in what types of ways they were
trying to he speaks of seeing the
results of players disliking the combat
system and lack of in-game content and
affirms that he plans to completely redo
the combat system and by July of 2011
the team had already implemented changes
to improve on shortcomings he spoke
about with patch 1.18 but it was just a
stop Gap to throw current players a bone
while version 2.0 or Realm Reborn was
being worked on even though A Realm
Reborn was a totally new game it would
still be called Final Fantasy 14 to game
back player trust because it would be
good
I swear meanwhile on the business side
of things October 2011 version 2.0 was
announced and current players of 14
would be given access to version 2.0 for
free with the character data all
transferable and uh monthly fees would
begin again in January 2012. okay that
one's not so good but at some point you
do have to make enough money to both
make and maintain the game that said
Square Enix made itself players did keep
paying monthly fees for at least three
months before 2.0's release they'd get a
permanent reduction in monthly fees I
mean I'm not gonna say it's great that
they're making you pay money to pay less
money but it is cool if you were
planning on playing the game anyways
after nearly two years of development in
November of 2012 servers for Final
Fantasy 14 1.0 were shut down in
preparation for an alpha test of A Realm
Reborn later that month but what had
never been seen before was the wave 1.0
shut down it was in miraculous fashion
with the calamitous events in game that
would play into the ongoing story of the
game and work as a parallel to his
development which then led directly into
a realm reborn's first trailer so what
was Yoshida going to do for Realm Reborn
well he allies a lot of this in a later
2014 GDC presentation Yoshida felt one
major issue was that the former team
were too focused on good graphics
instead of performance which is a a
major issue for an online game and part
of why the game had been so buggy so he
reeled back on trying to have state of
the art Graphics to make a game that was
actually playable I mean one example of
this is take this flower pot it is so
pretty it's beautiful and he hated it he
hated it with a passion it was
incredibly stupid to make not you you're
okay you see this flower pot contained
over 1 000 polygons and 150 lines of
Shader code in other words the same
amount of resources as a single player
character I think you can start to see
where there might be an issue by
including so many assets like this as
pretty as the game looked you couldn't
fit more than 20 characters on screen at
a time as a result which for a genre
titled A massively multiplayer that's
kinda an issue so none of that A Realm
Reborn would have crappy Graphics I mean
comparatively they were still fine for
an MMO next up on yoshida's list
game Masters at the time of creating
ff14 the square was fixated on having a
specific game Mastercraft each game
experience but with an MMO that quickly
becomes an issue because well they're
massive and have so many systems at play
that need to work in a multiplayer
setting so instead while he'd oversee
the project and quickly provide input
and approved design decisions he'd also
have a team of elite designers who he'd
trust to make major decisions as well so
they could quickly move forward this was
key to Yoshida as teams working on
different systems of ff14 version 1.0
apparently didn't communicate or work
together at all so we wanted to ensure
the teams understood what other teams
were doing and therefore could design a
more cohesive game next up a Reliance on
patches
because it had worked with ff11 square
thought they could just rely on a slow
release of patches to fix fundamental
flaws of the game but that wouldn't work
here Yoshida wasn't about that noise and
thought it was a terrible lack of
planning I know other thing he did by
the way was he forced less experienced
staff members to replay OG ff14 over and
over again to make sure that they
understood why it sucked you will play
the game damn it sir please no more more
ff14 more
you also had them play World of Warcraft
and other good MMOs so they could learn
what was good and bad he wanted to go
back to game design fundamentals and
focus on a fun gameplay experience which
is kind of key to the game you'd
actually want to play that included a
commitment to level design where you'd
have different teams work on different
regions of the game in order to Foster
competition within a square to create a
better and more fun area he viewed an
MMORPG like running a country where the
players are the citizens and like
Innovative citizens are unhappy they'll
move out of your country so it's
important for the devs to actively and
regularly listen to their citizens or
player and keep them on board and after
two years and eight months of work on
Final Fantasy 14 A Realm Reborn on
August 27 2013 it was finally released
and unlike OG ff14 new ff14 was viewed
as terrible
wait hold on sorry wrong version it was
viewed as
good like not the greatest thing ever
but surprisingly good in general the
sentiment was total shock at how much
Final Fantasy 14 Around Reborn had
improved compared to the original Final
Fantasy 14 by both critics and fans
alike it was even named the best MMO of
the Year by several outlets the game
sold well enough that by the fiscal year
of 2014 Square Enix allotted Final
Fantasy 14 as the reason they were
profitable again after a less than
stellar 2013. and thanks to their
subscription model Final Fantasy 14 just
kept making money to the point where
after multiple patches naoki yoshido
could finally work on genuine major
expansions these expansions weren't just
new story quests or raids I mean those
were there too each of them also
included major gameplay elements added
to the game from new character classes
to features like flying swimming and
Diving revamping the combat system new
areas playable races and more each
expansion only served to make the game
better more notable in the MMO community
and bring in yet a larger player base
through four expansions ff14 has also
gained notoriety as a beloved story in
the franchise which defies the MMO label
but lives up to the Final Fantasy name
and as content updates rolled out over
the decades since Yoshida still does his
letter from the producer routinely as a
live stream by April 2021 there were 22
million registered players for ff14 and
by the release of end Walker in 2021
that number had risen to 24 million not
only that but Final Fantasy 14 had
become the most profitable Final Fantasy
game ever for Square Enix and that is
how Final Fantasy 14 saved itself
you know the funny thing is before
writing this episode I actually thought
Final Fantasy 11 was a failure I had no
idea that had become so successful also
the more I read about how Yoshida
handled the ff14 situation the more
respect I've gained for him he seems
genuinely awesome anyways please
consider checking out our previous
episodes we have a whole playlist